kef en appel à l'otan moscou mettons
gardel contre une dangereuse escalade
depuis plusieurs jours la tension est
vive dans l'est de l'ukraine
de part et d'autre de la frontière russe
déploie des militaires la correspondance
à moscou d'antoine claireaux sergey
lavrov dit regretter la position des
capitales occidentales paris et berlin
en premier lieu les garants des accords
de minsk il regrette ce soutien
inconditionnel envers kiev
en dépit de son manque de volonté
politique concernant la mise en oeuvre
des accords de minsk mais aussi à propos
de son activité militaire au niveau de
la ligne de contact
mais est ce nouveau show nous avons
longuement ce jeu donne la réaction de
nos collègues occidentaux au
renforcement de l'infrastructure
militaire et au transfert des troupes
vers la ligne d'un impact dans le dôme
basse et décevantes provenant de toute
évidence nos collègues occidentaux
continuent à partir du principe qu'il
faut systématiquement soutenir les
autorités ukrainiennes
même leurs activités et déclarations les
plus inacceptables les souvenirs le
porte parole du kremlin l'a dit hier il
a répété aujourd'hui la situation est
grave la situation est préoccupante
il ne suffit que d'une étincelle d'une
provocation pour que les hostilités
reprennent et cette inquiétude selon
dimitri peskov ne semble pas partagée
par kiev
d'autres lieux d'autres capitales ont
été également informés de nos
préoccupations
effectivement la situation laisse à
désirer mais à l'heure actuelle nous ne
voyons aucune intention de la partie
ukrainienne de se calmer et 8 wild
abandonner la rhétorique belliqueuse
quant à lui sous prétexte d'une menace
éphémère contrôle et de contrôler leurs
forces armées déployées près de la ligne
de contact et qui sont le plus souvent
la raison de ses provocations du catwalk
avec une récup leur est pourtant la
diplomatie ukrainienne assure ne pas
vouloir la guerre ne pas chercher
l'escaladé
c'est donc le statu quo qui prévaut les
uns accusant les autres de ce regard de
tension